a new lawsuit claims a woman died after  drinking  real water ri team was the first to tell  you about this  inside the 8 news now app we've told you  about the nearly dozen of cases people  getting sick after drinking the las  vegas based company's water  the woman in her 60s died back in  november around the same time  other people say they got sick the  i-team spoke with an attorney  representing several families in  lawsuits  filed against the company they want  accountability no they want this to be  known  they want to make sure that what  happened to them and what they went  through  doesn't happen to anyone else the new  filing also claims  several women suffered miscarriages and  that an employee's dog  got sick after it ingested what lawyers  call a quote  bad batch in march the fda recommended  people just stop drinking the water and  stores  stop selling real water